this past year has been weird at my
house man
it's been weird because you know i i
look i know coveted never made it to
florida but
[Laughter]
in other parts of the country we had to
like shut down and stuff and um
we were in california at the time and we
were really shut the [ __ ] down and i
will tell you what man
you think you're in an honest
relationship until you spend a year
staring at that person for 24 hours a
day and then [ __ ] comes out of your
mouth that you were not you know my wife
said to me this is how i honestly got in
my house we were having sex and she was
on top of me
and she just looked down at me and she
goes
oh your face looks so stupid tonight
look that way
[Applause]
i said what she goes yeah i can't come
you're like like that or something i
don't like that at all
yeah oh it could [ __ ] honest real
quick and then so i asked her because it
was just us right and i was like okay
look man we've been married a long time
is there anything you've always wanted
to do
but you've just been too scared to ask
and she was like
i said i go let's hear it let's hear it
cheers okay okay okay oh okay
you're not going to think i'm weird are
you
and i was like well
i'm already kind of hard so no
[Laughter]
i go what's the deal she was okay all
right
i've always wanted to stand behind you
and hold your penis when you pee and i
was like what
by the way has anyone done that has
anyone done that
you've done that with him
you did it with him
okay
yo man i can tell by your face i didn't
like it either dude
it felt like someone else was flying the
[ __ ] plane i didn't like that [ __ ] at
all and my wife was all willy nilly on
takeoff and landing she was like
so here's the deal and i'm going to ask
you about your experience after right so
she stands behind me dude what's your
name man
james she stands behind me and she grabs
my dick and she just goes do it
and i was like i don't know if that's
how you pee but that doesn't [ __ ]
work for me you know
and she just starts to go like this dude
ready she starts to go
she goes i feel like luke skywalker i
love it
and she leans in and she whispers i am
your father
and i was like
hey don't whisper that with my dick in
your hand i don't like that
and she just started to shake it james
she was like this and she started to go
like this does it hurt when i do that
does it hurt when i do that how does
that hurt if i shake it really hard if i
share really hard that doesn't hurt your
penis i shake it like this
and then she just started to tap it
against my leg right and she goes so
when you're walking down the street
how does that not distract you isn't it
feel like there's a little person in
your pants like yoo-hoo pay attention to
me
yoo-hoo i'm right here i'm like no but
now i will
and then she just goes like this do it
now pee do it now and i was like i i
can't perform under that kind of
pressure
and it's not a toy look when she's naked
i'm never down by her going hey make it
talk can it say something
can you make a voice come out of here oh
i'd love to hear droopy dog hey
hey that really makes me mad
by the way
i want to tell you all something
women about every guy you've ever met in
your life and definitely every man in
here
okay
i don't know why i'm gonna say this
every guy in here
has felt really proud of himself
because
while they've been peeing they've been
cleaning the toilet
every guy in here is like i'm a
sharpshooter
there was something dried on the toilet
babe i got it off of there i cleaned the
bathroom
oh every guy and if it's if it's a
little tough little thing you get closer
to it you're like
sometimes you push extra hard you're
like
oh if you haven't [ __ ] your pants while
you're peeing you haven't lived yet
it's gross we're gross people that's how
you know what i mean we're gross people
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]